.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Ruhige Musik *
Hier im Unterengadin, weit oben
im kleinen rätoromanischen Ftan,
wohnt ein Mann.
Einer von vielen, die hier
der Bergidylle wegen hausen -
einer von vielen mit einem
mehr oder weniger grossen Vogel -
jedoch der Einzige
mit einem richtigen Vogel.
Werner Fischers gefiederte
Lebensgefährtin heisst Bubo
und ist eine Uhu-Dame.
Wie es dazu kam
und was das für ihn als Mensch und
für sie als Vogel zu bedeuten hat,
das möchte ich erfahren.
Ja, sie ist sicherlich eine sehr
intensive und enge Begleiterin,
wenn man das so sagen kann -
Beziehung hin oder her.
Natürlich ist sie ein Haustier,
aber sie ist ein bisschen mehr.
Ohne sie ...
Wenn ich mal früh weggehe
und spät heimkomme
und sie den ganzen Tag nicht sehe,
dann fehlt mir schon etwas.
Dann bin ich sehr froh,
dass sie da ist und auf mich wartet.
Sie ist für mich
nicht nur ein Haustier,
wie etwa eine Katze oder ein Hund.
Du bist ein bisschen mehr,
nicht wahr?
Das, was wir hier machen,
ist ein Spaziergang,
Freude haben an der Natur,
am Wetter,
vielleicht auch
ein bisschen abschalten.
Für mich ist es sehr schön,
wenn das Tier dabei ist.
Wenn ich sehe, was sie alles sieht,
ist es fantastisch,
das mitzuerleben.
Es freut mich zu sehen,
dass es ihr so gut geht,
sonst würde sie
nicht so ruhig sitzen.
Werners Vater war Biologe
und päppelte zu Hause immer wieder
verwaiste oder verletzte Tiere auf.
Als Zwölfjähriger half Werner
bei der Pflege und Auswilderung
einer Eule -
für ihn ein Schlüsselerlebnis,
wie er heute sagt.
Und so setzte er sich
vor einigen Jahren in den Kopf,
einen Uhu als Heimtier zu halten.
Ein Zoo in Basel
hat Werner diesen Wunsch erfüllt.
In der Schweiz werden keine Uhus
ausgebrütet oder gezüchtet.
Es gibt genug,
siewerden relativ alt
und darum braucht man auch
in den Zoos keine mehr.
Sie mussten sicher sein,
dass ich den Uhu auch nehmen würde.
Das haben wir so vereinbart.
Dann haben sie
den Uhu für mich brüten lassen.
Sie wäre nicht auf der Welt,
wenn ich nicht gesagt hätte,
dass ich einen Uhu wolle.
Mit einer Woche kam sie zu mir -
in der Phase,
in der sie die Augen öffnen.
In dieser Phase muss man da sein,
um den ersten Kontakt zu haben,
für den Imprint,
weil der Vogel
als Erstes mich sieht,
und nicht sein richtiges Mami.
Da war einerseits Freude,
aber auch sehr viel Anspannung
und sehr viel Ungewissheit,
wie das
mit diesem Tier funktioniert.
Ich habe zwar
eine Ausbildung gemacht
und mich intensiv
damit beschäftigt.
Ich beschäftigte mich sehr lange
mit der Aufzucht eines Jungtiers.
Aber in der Literatur
geht es meistens nur um Greifvögel,
und über Eulen
gibt es praktisch nichts.
Einen Uhu aufzuziehen
ist nicht allzu schwierig,
aber es braucht halt schon
ein gewisses Know-how,
um es richtig zu machen.
Aber es geht schnell.
Innerhalb von zwei, drei Wochen
sind sie aus dem Gröbsten raus
und dann ist da sehr viel Freude,
wenn man sieht,
wie sich das Tier entwickelt
und mit allem spielt,
was man ihm gibt.
Wie andere Tiere auch
sind sie in der Jugendphase
extrem verspielt.
Das endet dann leider sehr schnell.
Streicheln und Anfassen
toleriert sie teilweise,
aber in der ersten Phase war das
viel mehr, und das geht nicht mehr.
Was machst du da oben?
Au! Nein, Bubo, nicht so fest.
Bubo? Bubo?
Bubo, was soll das?
Kannst du bitte
wieder runterkommen?
Danke, Bubo. Du bist eine Liebe.
Es ist kein Hund, keine Katze
oder kein Meerschweinchen,
mit dem man sehr viel spielen kann.
Das ist einfach so.
Es ist ein Wildvogel.
Ein müder Wildvogel,
der aber in gewissen Phasen
doch sehr zutraulich ist.
Im Moment ist gerade morgens früh
viel möglich.
Am Abend ist das nicht mehr so.
Aber jetzt
ist sie in der Ruhephase.
Stimmt das?
Um in der Schweiz
einen Uhu halten zu dürfen,
musste Fischer die Falknerei-
und die Jagdprüfung absolvieren.
Fünf Jahre
hat es anschliessend gedauert,
bis die zuständigen Ämter
des Kantons Graubünden
der falknerischen Haltung
von Bubo zustimmten.
D.h., sie darf
mit Peilsender gesichert fliegen,
jedoch nicht selber jagen.
Das stoische,
unnahbare Wesen der Eulen
hat beim Menschen seit jeher
unterschiedliche Gefühle ausgelöst.
Die einen sahen sie
als spirituelle Führerinnen,
die anderen als Botinnen des Todes.
Für Werner ist sie ganz einfach
die perfekte Begleiterin.
* Mysteriöse Musik *
Nein, Bubo, warten. Nein.
Bubo, nein. Bubo, nein.
Was gibt sie dir denn?
Kannst du das in Worte fassen?
Was tut dir gut mit ihr?
Ich bin ein spezieller Mensch,
und der Uhu ist auch speziell.
Uhus sind vom Wesen her
sehr ähnlich wie ich.
Sie flattern oder fliegen
nicht stundenlang wild rum,
sondern sie sind ruhige Tiere,
die diese Ruhe auch ausstrahlen.
Das mache ich meistens auch.
Von dem her
passen wir sehr gut zusammen.
Das hat mir an dem Tier so gefallen.
Und natürlich die Herausforderung,
einen Uhu zu halten,
obwohl andere
das für unmöglich gehalten haben.
Das zeigt,
dass es nicht ganz unmöglich ist.
Aber es braucht
viel Zeit und Aufwand.
Bubo. Up, up.
Der Uhu ist ein Ansitzjäger,
d.h., er hält im Sitzen
Ausschau nach Beute,
fängt sie und setzt sich wieder hin.
* Bubo ruft. *
Im Vergleich zu anderen Raubvögeln
fliegt er daher insgesamt
nur ein paar Minuten am Tag.
Bubo.
Bubo hat eine Flügelspannweite
von 1,65 m
und ist etwas über 2 kg schwer.
Sie liegt damit im Durchschnitt
eines männlichen Uhus -
die Weibchen
sind normalerweise grösser.
Auf dem Speiseplan
stehen Mäuse, Ratten,
Eichhörnchen, Hasen und Vögel.
Es muss immer
ein positiver Reiz vorhanden sein,
und der ist für sie das Futter.
Der Vogel kommt nicht zu mir,
weil ich so ein netter Mensch bin,
sondern weil es hier
etwas zu fressen gibt.
Das muss man
auch wissen als Falkner:
dass man kein Freund des Vogels ist.
Aber der Vogel merkt irgendwann,
dass er mit dem Falkner zusammen
ein gutes Team ist.
Der Falkner bringt ihn dorthin,
wo es Wild, Tiere, Nahrung hat.
Hei, ei, ei, ist es lecker?
Ui, ui. Fertig. Fertig, Bubo. Komm.
Fertig. Fertig.
* Ruhige Musik *
Bubo sieht die Beziehung zu Werner
Fischer also nicht als Freundschaft,
sondern eher unsentimental
als Kollaboration.
Werner Fischer arbeitet als Lehrer,
Bergführer und Falkner.
Der Klimaschutz liegt ihm am Herzen.
Schon viele Jahre bevor das Thema
auf der Agenda der Weltpolitik stand,
entwickelte Werner Ideen
für ein möglichst nachhaltiges Leben.
Als ich hierherkam,
baute ich als Erstes das Haus
nach meinen Bedürfnissen um.
Ich wollte die Energie der Sonne
in das umwandeln,
was ich brauchen kann:
Strom plus Wärme.
Das ist seit nunmehr 20 Jahren
ein Thema bei mir
und ist mir mittlerweile
auch fast gelungen.
Ich kann Strom erzeugen
und thermisch und mit Fotovoltaik
warmes Wasser und Wärme produzieren.
Den Rest mache ich mit dem Ofen.
Das ist eine tolle Sache.
Werner tut das alles
für sich selbst und seine Tiere.
Mit den menschlichen Beziehungen
habe es nie so richtig geklappt.
Zum einen sei da immer
die Angst gewesen,
sich anpassen und das selbstbestimmte
Leben aufgeben zu müssen.
Zum anderen sei ein Leben
ohne die gängigen Haushaltsmaschinen,
ohne Fernseher oder Smartphone,
für viele Menschen zu unpopulär
und zu anstrengend.
Ich sehe es als wunderbare Sache,
so zu leben.
Ich versuche es auch
den Jugendlichen zu vermitteln,
die in dieser Konsum-
und Wegwerfgesellschaft leben.
Darum zeige ich ihnen, dass man
Haushaltsgegenstände wie z.B. Messer
auch mit Rohstoffen herstellen kann,
die bereits vorhanden sind
und die man sonst wegwerfen würde.
Das funktioniert prächtig.
Werner macht
seine Küchen- und Jagdmesser selber
aus ausgedienten Sägeblättern
und Geweih.
Er züchtet Ratten für Bubo -
und Fische für sie beide.
Also ein fast autarkes,
klimaneutrales Leben, das er vorlebt.
Ich versuche, mein Bestes zu geben
und das auch vorzuleben.
Wenn jemand mitmachen möchte,
sehr gerne.
Aber ich glaube, es ist fast nicht
möglich, dass ich mit meiner Arbeit
unsere Konsumgesellschaft
verändern kann.
Ich finde es schon sehr tragisch,
dass ich mit meiner Rolle
ein Aussenseiter bin.
Das weiss ich, das ist mir klar.
Aber ich habe halt einen Vogel.
Viele Leute sagen,
ich hätte einen grossen Vogel,
und das stimmt halt schon.
Hallo, Habicht.
Neben einem sichtbaren
und einem unsichtbaren Vogel
hat Werner
gerade noch einen Pflegevogel.
Mit seinem fundierten Wissen
führt Werner nebenbei
eine kleine Auffangstation
für Greifvögel und Eulen.
Hallo, Habicht. Habicht.
Schau mal, jetzt gibt's
leckeres Essen für dich.
Hallo, Habicht.
Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui.
Ui, hast du Hunger.
Ui, Habicht, hast du Hunger.
Habicht, schau hier.
Schau hier, Habicht.
Hallo, Habicht, schau hier.
Schmeckt's dir? Oh, ist das lecker.
Der Uhu reicht mir nicht mehr.
Nein, so ist es nicht.
Es ist für mich irgendwie logisch,
dass ich mit meinem Wissen,
das ich dank meiner Arbeit
mit dem Uhu habe,
auch anderen Vögeln helfe,
falls es nötig ist.
Darum habe ich diese Pflegestation
für Greifvögel und Eulen aufgebaut.
Es macht ja Sinn, dass Leute,
die so ein Tier halten,
mit ihrem Wissen
solchen Tieren helfen.
Das ist ein Habicht,
der vermutlich eine Kollision hatte
und zu mir gekommen ist
und hier gepflegt wird -
in der Hoffnung, dass ich ihn
bald wieder auswildern kann.
Die Frage ist, ob wir die
Flugfähigkeit wieder hinbringen.
Er bekommt diese Chance.
Das mache ich gerne.
Die Hoffnung
stirbt ja bekanntlich zuletzt.
Fertig. Brav, Habicht.
Brav, Habicht.
Jetzt ruhst du dich aus,
damit du fit wirst.
Fertig, Habicht.
Wie sich später herausstellen wird,
handelt es sich bei diesem Jungvogel
nicht um einen Habicht,
sondern um einen Mäusebussard.
Der Unterschied ist bei Jungtieren
nur schwer erkennbar.
* Sanfte Musik *
Während sich die einen ausruhen,
geht es für die anderen
an die Arbeit.
Bubo macht heute eine kleine Reise.
Sie wurde nämlich
in den Kindergarten eingeladen.
Bubo!
Bubo, komm.
Wir machen einen Ausflug. Komm.
Ja, du kommst mit. Komm.
* Bubo macht leise Geräusche. *
Guten Morgen.
Guten Morgen, Bubo.
Komm, Bubo, komm.
Bubo, komm, aufsteigen.
* Bubo macht laute Geräusche. *
Ja, Bubo. Brave Bubo.
* Er spricht leise. *
Jetzt gehen wir in die Schule.
In den Kindergarten.
Der Besuch im Kindergarten
soll die Kinder
für die ansässigen Wildtiere
sensibilisieren.
Als Werk- und Sportlehrer
bringt Werner Fischer
das pädagogische Geschick mit,
das es im Umgang mit den Kindern
braucht.
Siehst du etwas, Bubo?
Was ist da draussen?
Wo sind wir jetzt?
Hallo, Bubo. Komm, aufsteigen. Brav.
Aufsteigen. Komm.
Aufsteigen, hopp. Hopp.
Brav.
Uhus sind nachtaktiv.
Am Tag sind sie eher im Ruhemodus
und auch nicht sehr hungrig.
Die fünf- bis sechsjährigen Kinder
haben somit nichts zu befürchten.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Sind bei euch gerade
die Eulen das Thema?
Ja.
- Was habt ihr schon alles gemacht?
Wir machen z.B. ...
Dort hinten sind Eulenmasken.
Dort haben wir aus Papier
Eulen gemacht.
Die mit dem Braunstich
ist von mir.
Und dann zeichnen wir
auch noch Eulen und so.
Und du siehst ja da mal ...
Hier hätten wir nicht sollen.
Hier hätte man ...
Aber ich habe gefragt,
ob ich die ausmalen darf
und ich durfte,
drum male ich jetzt aus.
In der Waldspielgruppe kam er
auch schon mal vorbei mit dem Kauz.
Heute kommt er hier vorbei.
Weisst du, wer euch heute besucht?
- Ähm, ja.
Erzähl mal.
- Ein Püf.
Auf Romanisch heisst Eule "Püf".
Auf Romanisch ist es "Püf".
Das ist ein riesiger Vogel.
Ja.
- So gross!
Ja, aber ich habe
trotzdem keine Angst.
Der ist so gross wie Anja.
Fast so gross wie ich.
Ein bisschen kleiner.
Bis hier kommt er.
- Fast ...
Der macht eigentlich gar nichts.
Der bleibt nur auf der Hand.
Schau mal, was da alles ist.
Schau mal!
Hallo zusammen.
Schau mal hier!
Ui, ui, ui.
So.
Also.
Wir sind jetzt hier.
Ihr seht hier einen Uhu.
Wir werden jetzt gemeinsam ein paar
Sachen zu diesem Tier besprechen.
Ich werde euch fragen,
was ihr alles wisst über den Uhu.
Bei euch ist das ja
gerade das Thema.
Ihr seht, sie ist eben aufgewacht.
Wach ist sie schon länger. Jetzt
sitzt sie hier auf meiner Hand.
Ihr müsst auch keine Angst haben.
Sie ist angebunden.
Meine erste Frage an euch:
Gibt es bei uns im Wald Uhus?
- Ja.
Ja. Wo?
Im Wald.
- Wer hat schon mal einen gesehen?
(Verschiedene) Ich!
In Ardez.
So ein grosser Uhu?
Ja. Ein bisschen kleiner.
Es war eher ein Euli.
Wieso sieht man ihn
denn so selten im Wald?
Weil er so viele bunte Federn hat,
die aussehen wie Bäume.
Genau, er ist getarnt und sieht so
braun und fleckig aus wie ein Baum.
Darum sieht man ihn fast nicht.
* Ein Kind spricht unverständlich. *
Das sind ihre Unterhosen.
Die sind hier unten.
Die sind ganz, ganz fein
und geben warm.
Dann ist ihr warm.
Sommer und Winter.
Auch wenn es draussen kalt ist.
Und die sind da unten am Bauch.
Nicht? Die sind von dir.
Ist die von dir?
Willst du die essen?
(Kind) Die mag sie nicht.
- Sie wollte sie nicht essen.
Was Kinder natürlich immer wissen
wollen, ist, was ein Uhu frisst.
Was frisst Bubo?
Frisst der Uhu Rüebli?
* Stimmengewirr *
Frisst ein Uhu das?
- (Kinder) Ja.
Oh, was ist das?
Eine Maus!
Das ist keine Maus,
das ist eine Ratte.
Wer hat so eine schon mal gesehen?
(Junge) Ich, in den Ferien,
aber eine grössere.
Schaut mal, wie sie schaut.
Sie hat sie schon gesehen.
Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui.
Wer hat noch eine Frage?
- (Kinder) Ich!
Wie viele Mäuse
frisst sie an einem Tag?
An einem Tag?
Was denkst du, wie viele frisst sie?
- Zwei?- Vier?
Ja, zwei bis drei so kleine
oder eine grosse.
Normalerweise
würde sie jetzt nichts fressen.
Wollen wir schauen,
ob sie die Ratte trotzdem frisst?
* Bubo macht aufgeregte Geräusche. *
Komm, aufsteigen Bubo.
(Kind) Oh mein Gott.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Was für Bubo
ein willkommener Snack ist,
mag für die Kinder im ersten Moment
ein ziemlicher Schock sein.
Dennoch gehört es zur Umweltbildung
nun mal dazu,
die Natur in ihrer unverblümten,
ehrlichen Form zu zeigen.
Auch Bubo muss ihre Umgebung
kennen- und akzeptieren lernen.
So, Bubo, jetzt gehen wir einkaufen.
Jetzt gehen wir einkaufen.
Schau, da ist dein Freund, der Hund.
Da ist dein Freund, der Hund.
Ihr zwei seid aber konzentriert.
Wir sind immer konzentriert. Brav.
Sitze und warte hier,
ich kaufe uns Mittagessen.
Sie hat ja Angst vor Hunden.
Ist es unproblematisch,
dass sie allein
so nahe bei einem Hund wartet?
Das ist auch die Idee,
dass sie lernt,
dass der Hund ihr nichts tut.
Den kennt sie, mehr oder weniger,
und er sie auch.
Es gehört zum Training dazu ...
Tschau!
... dass sie Kontakt
mit diesem oder anderen Hunden hat
und lernt, das zu akzeptieren
und zu sehen, dass der Hund
ihr nichts macht.
Bubo, komm, wir gehen.
* Bellen *
* Ruhige Musik *
Ja, Bubo. Komm.
Schau mal, Bubo.
Schau mal, Velofahrer.
Velofahrer. Schau mal!
Musst du langsam
etwas verlangen für Fotos?
Fünf Franken.
- Eine Maus.
Immer eine Maus.
Am Morgen waren wir in der Schule.
Schule, Kindergarten.
Ja, ja, ja.
Sollen wir dich auswildern?
Du, nein.
Wir wildern dich nicht aus.
Nein, die möchte nicht. Die will
jetzt lieber spazieren gehen.
Dich auswildern ...
Nerven dich die Schaulustigen,
oder begibst du dich mit Bubo
gern unter Leute,
weil du diese Aufmerksamkeit
schön findest?
Ja, nerven ...
Es sind halt immer
die gleichen Fragen:
nach Alter, Gewicht und so.
Aber ich mache das
aus einem ganz anderen Grund.
Als Falkner sagt man "abtragen".
Es geht darum, dass der Vogel
an sein Umfeld habituiert wird,
an sein Habitat gewöhnt wird.
So lernt Bubo
die ganzen Umwelteinflüsse,
die auf sie einwirken, kennen.
Nur so ist es möglich, mit dem Vogel
draussen unterwegs zu sein
und Öffentlichkeitsarbeit
zu betreiben.
Wenn sie das ganze Jahr
nur in der Voliere sitzen würde,
könnten solche Reize
schnell zu Stress führen.
* Kirchenglocken *
* Ruhige Musik *
Dass ihm das Tier
fast lieber sei als der Mensch,
könnte man leicht annehmen,
wenn man Werner Fischer beobachtet.
Mir scheint eher,
er ist ein Botschafter
dieses imposanten Vogeltiers.
Einer, dem es
um die gegenseitige Akzeptanz,
ums Miteinander
von Mensch und Natur geht.
* Bubo ruft. *
Ja, genial.
Uhu.
Schau mal, was es Leckeres gibt.
Was es heute Leckeres gibt.
Sie ist schon fast
deine Lebenspartnerin
oder ein Familienersatz,
kann man das so sagen?
Ja, in gewissem Sinn schon.
Ich habe ja keine Familie, und von
daher ist sie schon ein Haustier,
aber eben auch ein bisschen mehr.
Mir bringt es schon etwas,
mit ihr unterwegs zu sein
und zu sehen,
dass es ihr gut geht.
Das ist eine schöne Sache.
Ein Uhu wird in der Wildnis
ca. 25 Jahre alt,
in wohlbehüteter Gefangenschaft
können es 50 werden.
Damit wird Bubo
ihren Besitzer wohl überleben.
Ja, das beschäftigt mich schon.
Was passiert,
wenn ich mal krank bin ...
... und eine Weile
nicht für sie da sein kann?
Wer kann die Pflege von mir
übernehmen und mit ihr arbeiten?
Klar wäre es möglich,
sie nur in der Voliere zu halten
und ihr das Futter da reinzugeben.
Aber ich glaube,
sie wäre nicht so glücklich,
wenn sie praktisch nur
in der Voliere wäre.
Bubo, up!
Trotz der Sorgen über die Zukunft
überwiegt für Werner Fischer
die Freude an seinem
in der Schweiz einmaligen Haustier.
Brave Bubo!
Bubo begleitet ihn auf seiner Reise,
vermag ihn mit ihrem gelassenen Gemüt
zu erden und lebt vor,
was es heisst, sich über die ganz
kleinen Dinge im Leben zu freuen.
Bleibt die Frage,
ob es sie denn auch glücklich macht -
dieses Leben.
Was würdest du jemandem sagen,
der sagt, das sei ein wildes Tier,
das in Freiheit leben sollte,
und nicht in Gefangenschaft?
Das ist eine Grundsatzfrage.
Dann müssten wir die Haltung
von allen Haustieren und Wildtieren
infrage stellen,
ob man das soll und darf.
Ich probiere einfach
diese Tierhaltung
so naturnah wie möglich
durchzuführen.
Wenn ich diesen Vogel beobachte,
hat er schon viele Möglichkeiten.
Natürlich lebt er nicht
in der Natur, nicht in Freiheit.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl,
es geht ihm gut.
Und wie wir gesehen haben,
kann ich mit ihr auch etwas machen -
sei es für wissenschaftliche Zwecke
oder um Kindern und Erwachsenen
zu zeigen,
wie so ein Tier lebt
und welchen Gefahren
es in der heutigen Zeit
ausgesetzt ist.
Man darf darüber denken,
wie man will,
aber die beiden
scheinen zueinander zu passen.
Und sie sind füreinander
von grosser Wichtigkeit -
wenn auch
aus unterschiedlichen Gründen.
* Sanfte Musik *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023